[Music]
hey everyone welcome back we are now
talking about how you can use the l1
norm to robusta file your statistics and
your regressions so this is something
I've talked a lot about before and is
one of the absolute most important
aspects of sparsity in general is how
you can use this to robusta Phi all of
the things you've been doing forever
okay and in fact there's actually kind
of an interesting history here so when
when you grow up in any kind of
engineering math or applied math
department today you are inundated with
least-squares solutions
l2 norms we don't even think about the
world in terms of other norms we think
about the Euclidean distance the two
norm least square solutions pretty much
default if someone tells you to solve a
system of equations and it's under
determined or over determined you use
the least squares or the minimum l
2-norm solution okay but historically
hundreds of years ago there was actually
a debate about whether or not people
should be using the two norm or the one
norm and there were all of these
different attributes and virtues of
these different norms so it wasn't as
obvious that you should just use the two
norm over the one norm and I think a lot
of the reason people use the two norm is
because it's computationally easier it's
easier to prove results it's easier to
code up and have these solutions be fast
and accurate but now we're finding in
this era of compressed sensing and
sparsity that kind of l1 optimization l1
regression and regularization has a
really really important role in modern
statistics and modern data processing in
modern machine learning ok and that's
what I'm going to talk to you about here
is this idea I'm gonna start with the
simplest example that we've all seen
before which is just linear regression
okay so we're gonna have a bunch of data
points and we're gonna code this up but
we're gonna have a bunch of data points
okay and those data points are gonna
have some rough distribution I'm just
gonna draw a line through them right
they fit some some distribution this
would be some axes of inputs and outputs
and so we're going to assume that let's
call this X and let's call this B and
let's say that this these data points
we're going to model these data points
we just see these data points we're
going to model them as a line as a
linear fit we're gonna say a times X
equals B so we know X and B for all
these data points and we might try to
solve for this a vector sorry this a
slope that would model the slope of that
line okay so so that's that's one thing
you can do and you would often do this
using least squares we talked about this
in Chapter one on the singular value
decomposition how you could find the
slope of this line using the least
square solution so what you would
literally do is you would you would have
a bunch of points here this would be
like you know X 1 B 1 X 2 B 2 all the
way up to like X and B N and they don't
have to be ordered from left to right
that could be random order and then you
would have this this kind of you know X
1 X 2 dot dot down to X n vector and you
would have a B 1 B 2 dot dot dot down to
B and vector okay and you would say that
this is equal to so the B vector is
equal to the X vector times a number a
and we're trying to solve for this
number a now of course because there's
noise on this and this is not a perfect
model this this doesn't perfectly model
the real world this line this is never
gonna exactly equal right so I'm never
gonna find an A that makes this exactly
equal and so what we're going to do is
find an a that minimizes the sum of the
square of the error okay so what we're
going to do is we're gonna solve for a
that minimizes we're gonna minimize kind
of a X this vector X minus this vector B
we're gonna minimize some norm of that
error okay so we're going to minimize
the
gnorm of that error and we're going to
solve for the a that minimizes the norm
of that error now what you're used to
doing the least square solution the kind
of the SVD the singular value
decomposition are pseudo inverse
solution that you're used to that almost
everyone uses would minimize the two
norm of this error okay so this is my
error here error but this has a Kaylee's
heel it has a huge glaring problem and
that huge glaring problem is that if I
have an outlier if I have an outlier
here so some value that is not close to
my true distribution maybe my
measurement just was wrong that day
maybe my machine broke or fritzed out or
you know somebody tripped on the sensor
something bad happened and you get this
bad outlier when I minimize the two norm
error when I try to find the a that
minimizes the two norm error or the sum
of the squares of the errors this is
literally this error here this two norm
error is literally the sum of the
squares of each of those little error
terms term by term so I would take all
of this little point by point errors and
I would square them and add them up and
maybe I would take the square root of
all of that what did this outlier does
this outlier massively skews the entire
distribution because the square error
here is so much bigger than for all of
these little points it will change the
entire distribution to get closer to
that outlier because this squared error
penalize --is that distance so much okay
I drew it a little cartoonish it
wouldn't be that bad but it would shift
the entire distribution far away from
the true solution and that's a big
problem okay so long story short
outliers and corrupt measurements and
bad measurements massively skew the
least squares solutions okay and so
there is a really simple solution to
this a really simple way to handle
wires and to be robust to outliers and
that is to change this norm from a to
norm to a one norm so if instead of
trying to minimize the sum of the
squares of the errors of every single
data point to that fit instead what
we're going to do is with the one norm
we're going to just sum the absolute
values of each of the error terms so
we're not going to square anything we're
not going to take a bad outlier and make
it worse okay so what that's going to do
is it's going to add up the absolute
value of all of these errors but it's
not going to square anything that's what
the l1 norm is doing so we're gonna so
we're gonna code this up and we're gonna
see what happens when I have a normal
like a nice distribution with an outlier
and I solve for it using a least squares
solution and a minimum l1 norm error
solution okay so that's gonna make a big
difference and this minimum l1 norm
solution is going to be much much much
much much closer to the original true
distribution so this is going to be my
l1 and the l1 solution is going to be
robust very important it's going to be
robust to outliers it's going to be
robust to these big measurement errors
okay so that's that's what we're going
to do and we're going to code this up